the family of archie battersby have been
told his life support is due to be
withdrawn tomorrow morning after their
legal fight to move him from hospital to
a hospice came to an end
a last-ditch plea to the european court
of human rights to intervene in the case
was rejected following a high court
ruling that he must remain at raw london
hospital in whitechapel east london the
case has been in the courts for several
weeks
in june a judge first ruled that
archie's life support treatment should
stop
with doctors saying it was highly likely
that he was brain stem dead
archie's parents disputed this and were
then given permission to appeal against
the ruling at the court of
appeal judges there then rule that
archie's case should be reconsidered at
the high court
that judge ruled that doctors could
lawfully stop providing life support
treatment saying its continuation would
delay the inevitable
after appeals from archie's parents the
united nations requested that the 12
year old was to be kept alive while it
considered his case
but the supreme court dismissed the
family's application to appeal the
decision to remove life support with
treatment due to be withdrawn yesterday
morning
the family then applied to the european
court of human rights to intervene
but it said it would not interfere with
previous rulings by national courts
the family submitted an application to
the high court yesterday
seeking permission to move archie to a
hospice where his life support would be
removed
however today the high court judge ruled
that it wasn't in archie's best interest
to move him to a hospice the family then
turned to the court of appeal to
overturn the decision
and the echr decided again on a second
appeal that it wouldn't interfere in the
case
let's speak to our correspondent shiman
freeman powell who's outside the
hospital where archie is being treated
and shimano it looks as though this very
sad story is uh coming to an end
it really does and it has been an
extremely traumatic time for the
appearance of archie battersby ever
since april when they found him
unconscious at their home and since then
they've been enthralled in legal
challenges that you've just talked us
through trying initially to keep archie
battersby's life support ongoing but it
did become quite clear on wednesday that
the all legal options as uh to keep his
life support ongoing had been exhausted
so then the battle moved to trying to
get artie battersby transferred to a
hospice because uh holly dance archie's
mum had made it clear that she would
like for archie to spend his last days
in a peaceful environment and not in a
hospital which is often known for the
chaos and noise however it does seem
that that is not going to happen earlier
today the parents of archie battersby
had gone to the high court and the
courts have appealed to try and get
archie's move to a hospice but they
ruled that it was not in his best
interest to do so saying that his
condition was so unstable that even with
the best medical equipment that that
move wouldn't be in archie's best
interest and we're now hearing that
archie battersby's life support machine
will be turned off at 10 am tomorrow
morning we do have a statement from a
spokesperson for the campaign group
christian concern which is supporting
archie's family they've said that all
legal routes have now been exhausted the
family are devastated and are spending
precious time with archie right from the
very beginning archie's parents have
made it clear that they would not stop
fighting until the very end and no one
can dispute that that is exactly what
they've done they've been to the high
court they've been to the courts of
appeal they've been to the supreme court
and they've also been to the european
court for human rights but it does seem
that this story has now sadly come to an
end